All right. Good afternoon, everybody.
My name is Ralph DeBerardinis from the University of Texas Southwestern Medical
Center,
in Dallas, and I hope everyone is enjoying this
spectacular AACR meeting.
It's my honor to serve as the chair of this year's selection committee for the
AACR G.H.A. Clewes Award for
Outstanding Basic Cancer Research.
This is the AACR's oldest scientific achievement
award, and it recognizes investigators who have made
outstanding recent accomplishments in basic
cancer research.
Established in 1961 by the AACR and the
Eli Lilly
and Company,
the award honors Dr. G.H.A. Clewes,
who was the first research director of Eli Lilly and Company,
a founding member of AACR, and a past AACR
president.
The 2026 AACR G.H.A. Clewes Award for
Outstanding Basic Cancer Research is presented to Dr.
Andrew P. Feinberg, the Bloomberg Distinguished
Professor of Epigenetics at Johns Hopkins University.
Dr. Feinberg is widely recognized for his pioneering
discoveries defining the role of the epigenome in cancer
biology.
His work has provided a fundamental and mechanistic
framework for understanding how epigenetic
plasticity contributes to cancer development, progression, and
metastasis.
Early in his career, Dr. Feinberg discovered altered DNA
methylation in human cancer and later identified
loss of imprinting of the IGF2 locus in Wilms' tumor.
These findings established some of the earliest foundational
principles for the field of cancer epigenetics.
More recently, he has applied genomic approaches to define the
epigenomic alterations that distinguish normal tissues from
cancer and to illuminate how these changes regulate
cancer cell behavior.
His laboratory developed the first comprehensive whole genome
method for DNA methylation analysis and used it to
discover CpG
island shores, now recognized as major drivers of gene
expression differences among normal tissues, cancers,
and stem cell states.
He also led the first whole genome bisulfite
sequencing analysis of human cancer, revealing increased
methylation variability as a defining feature of colorectal cancer.
Dr. Feinberg has also made seminal contributions to understanding
cancer plasticity by integrating cancer biology with
concepts from information theory and statistical physics.
His work established epigenetic entropy as a defining feature of
the cancer epigenome and showed that chromatin
structure can deform this landscape in ways that promote
variable gene expression and phenotypic plasticity.
Importantly, Dr. Feinberg showed that metastasis in pancreatic
cancer can be driven by epigenetic plasticity in the
absence of metastasis-specific driver mutations,
challenging long-standing models of cancer progression.
He further identified linked metabolic and
epigenetic programs that promote distant
metastasis, revealing new mechanistic insights into tumor
progression and potential therapeutic vulnerabilities.
Dr. Feinberg's discoveries have had broad impact, changing
the modern field of cancer epigenetics and enabling the work
of researchers around the world.
His many honors include honorary doctorates from the
Karolinska Institute, the University of Uppsala, and the
University of Amsterdam, as well as the Harvey Prize, the Theodor
Leinen Medal, and the NIH Director's Pioneer Award.
It is my great honor to introduce the 2026
recipient of the AACR G.H.A. Clewes Award
for Outstanding Basic Cancer Research, Dr.
Andrew P. Feinberg.
This is incredibly kind. I really appreciate that.
Thank you, Ralph. That's just incredibly kind.
And I want to thank you, I want to thank the committee for bestowing
this honor on me. I was
absolutely floored when I got the email about this.
I checked the header on the thing to see if it was the Philadelphia server from
AACR, which it was, and I'm so grateful to AACR
for what they do, but also for this honor, and of
course, to Lilly for sponsoring the honor, for all of you for being here.
I'm very, very grateful to the colleagues that, I've
worked with,
colleagues, people senior to me, people junior to me that I work with.
That's what makes this all so wonderful to do, and the community all gets together
in places like this. And I also want to tell
my wife, Isabelle, how much I appreciate her support through
all these decades of hard work. It's a lot of work,
as you know, to do science, and there are a lot of frustrations.
And there's this reviewer number three out there who torments
me, and you, and it's always number three, and it's even on the grants it's
number three. But,
for the young people who are listening or maybe watch the recording,
don't let that discourage you. If you think you're right, you think you have
something interesting to say, usually the reviewers mean
well. Try not to get upset about it.
Try to deal with it, and you should be fine.
So, thank you again for all of this.
So, I want to talk today about epigenetic mechanisms of cancer progression,
and
I want toThese are my affiliations, I'm mostly at
Johns Hopkins. I have joint appointments at these other institutions Hopkins has
meant a lot to me in terms of defining me and also where I could
flourish. I've been away from there, but also back there, and I'm grateful for
that. And then the work I'm going to talk about was supported by
NIH, by Celgene, which got eaten by another
company,
and by the Bloomberg Philanthropies.
But mostly I want to acknowledge the amazing support of NIH
throughout my career and the National Cancer Institute in particular, without
which none of us would be doing what we've done.
And I think it's made a huge difference in our ability to maybe
either do the foundational work that's going to lead to therapies, which is kind of
what I do, but also lead to the therapies themselves.
So,
actually this picks up right on-- I don't know what Ralph was going to say, but
this picks up right on this point. So in 2005, I wrote this
review paper,
in Nature Reviews Genetics,
with a couple other colleagues who helped me,
just on what was the sort of view at the time of the
mutational genetic basis of cancer.
That there are mutations, and they lead to benign tumors
and either oncogene mutations or tumor suppressor gene mutations and then
so further things. And at each step, there are going to be mutations that lead
to continued
growth of the tumor spread and so forth.
And a couple levels that didn't...
Of course, that's right, at least in terms of the early stages of cancer.
Of course, finding these mutations has made an enormous difference
in saving patients' lives and so forth.
But there seemed to be more to the story than that, especially with regards to
the malleability of the cancer, its sort of shape-shifting ability, and
particularly in the later stages, even in the earlier stages of establishing a
basis for tumors. So I proposed this thing, I call this epigenetic
progenitor model of cancer, and it isn't meant to contradict
the genetics, it's meant to complement that, of course.
And the idea is that there might be epigenetic changes in normal tissue.
I called them changes in tumor
progenitor genes. We now know what those are.
After Yamanaka did what he did and other people did, we now know that these are
stem cell-related factors that are related to the stem
cell state and the plasticity in early development, but that lead to
expanded or epigenetically altered precursor cells.
And then epigenetics plays continued roles through the development of
cancer, but particularly in metastasis.
And it never made sense to me that a tumor might escape from an
adverse environment, say hypoxia, by undergoing a
mutation, but then finds itself in a new environment where there's a lot of blood
supply and now it's a hyperoxic environment. What's it going to do?
It's going to mutate again and then somehow completely switch that?
That makes no sense to me. So I thought that in that particular area,
the epigenetics might be particularly important too.
So this is the idea that cancer is a disease of epigenetic plasticity.
And even with regards to the mutations that cause cancer,
even in the earliest stages, they cause cancer likely
because of increasing epigenetic plasticity.
And in
about 10 years after that first review was written, I was asked by the
editor at Nature Reviews Genetics to revisit this question now that we knew a lot
about the genes, the Genome Project was done.
And I came up with a scheme for defining these genes as sort of three Ms.
So you have epigenetic modulators, modifiers, and mediators of
epigenetic plasticity. And what is that?
So the modulators would be things that activate or repress the
epigenetic machinery. They could be mutations, they could be the
environment, they could be the extracellular environment,
and they could be some of the... Actually, we now know that some of the genes that
are mutated in gatekeeping mutations in early cancers actually
induce epigenetic changes indirectly.
And then the targets of those are the modifiers. That is the epigenetic machinery.
Now bear in mind that the epigenetic machinery itself turned out to
be the most common types of mutations in
cancer.
In certain leukemias, it's the earliest changes, but in solid tumors, they
often occur later.
But those are the genes that change DNA methylation and change chromatin,
and then their targets are the genes that define the landscape.
Those would be the actual genes that are getting modified and getting either turned
on abnormally or turned off abnormally, or just becoming
more variable in the expression. That would be this flattening of the landscape so
that things could sort of move both ways.
The typical way you'll see a lecture where people talk about cancer is that
something differentiates, then it goes back to being a stem cell, then it goes down
and differentiates down another pathway.
And I don't contradict that idea. However, our own data, when
we started to develop methods for measuring this mathematical thing that Ralph
referred to of epigenetic entropy, suggests that the cancers are almost
moving onto another plane, a sort of a flattened plane, where they can change
states back and forth among many different states, so that you could say that
that's sort of lying over this field.
They have a number of latent states that they can move between
because of this increased plasticity. So that's the idea of this.
Around the time that I started to write
this,
I got approached by a
pediatric oncologist, who then wound up helping me with this, named Michael
Kadovsky. And he did a postdoctoral fellowship with me.
And he was interested in looking at ALL, which is what he studies,
and this led to a project,
to see, well, what happens to the epigenetic landscape in this relatively simple
type of cancer. His argument was that pediatric leukemias are
less complicated. They're often defined by a single chromosome rearrangement,
and maybe that would be a less sort of complex way of
looking at these hypotheses about epigenetic plasticity.
And what he found was that there was an astonishingly
convergent set of epigenetic mediators of diverse genetic
drivers. In other words, there were a number of mutations,
like for example, these are rearrangements, like ETV6-RUNX1 or a
hyperdiploid state, or rearrangements of TCF3,
PBX1. And all of these led to the
same set-of about, I don't know, 500
genes showing increased plasticity with increased variability of
expression and increased DNA methylation entropy, including each other.
So if you had a rearrangement of ETV6-RUNX1, this
TCF3, PBX1, both of those genes wound up becoming highly
entropic and showing variable expression.
So they were all converging on this sort of highly
plastic state in some way. And in order to answer that
question,
we asked whether or not there was a relationship
of gene expression entropy. So if you try to do
a gene regulatory modeling, you're looking at the co-expression of
different pairs of genes. But there's a mathematician at Cambridge who developed a
method for looking at the entropy of gene
expression and the co-expression of entropic genes.
And we used her model and found that if you do that and you look at the
variable expression of these genes showing epigenetic entropy, they converge
on a hub called UHRF1, which we would
then predict this would be our
epigenetic modifier. So these rearrangements are the modulators.
This would be the modifier, and then this plasticity of a large number of genes
would be the
mediators. And I never heard of UHRF1, but it turns out to be a gene that's
been mutated in prostate cancer, and it is a
bridge between DNA methylation and chromatin.
It's one of these giant proteins that connects up chromatin
modifications to DNA methylation.
And if you knock that down, then these leukemic cells don't
grow anymore in soft agar. So that was that
result.
So
after that project was done, I started to focus more
on-- I came back to a question that I'd studied earlier, and I'll show you that
earlier experiment in just a minute, but looking at pancreatic
cancer, and that's been the main thing that the lab's been working on for...
Well, there was a period I worked on this about 10 years ago, eight
years ago, and then there was a little between period looking at leukemia, and
now we've come back looking at pancreatic cancer
in great earnest over the last
six or seven years.
And I want to show you two results from that.
First, the first result has to do with what happens in the earliest
stages of pancreatic cancer formation.
So as you know, pancreatic cancer arises from
premalignant neoplasms called panins, which
are in humans always involved a KI ras
mutation, and that is a process of acinar-ductal
metaplasia. So this graduate student, Emily Lowe, did
experiments where she did laser capture microdissection,
isolated the panins and also the other parts of the pancreas,
and then asked, looking at the whole genome, "Well, where does
the DNA methylation pattern across the genome of a
panin lie with regards to the acinar and the ducts?" And it
lies right between them. So if you look at the acinar
thing, which is in red here, it's in between the panins,
and the... I'm sorry. If you look at the panins, which are green,
it lies between the acinar and the ducts. So it's in this transition state.
So there's the DNA methylation pattern for ADM from human
tumors. And then she took this model
in which
you
can activate KLF4, which was shown by a Japanese
group to induce acinar-ductal metaplasia in the absence
of the K-ras mutation. Now, you can't call it a panin, but it
looks like a panin, and the pathologist can't tell it apart, but it doesn't have a
mutation. So it's a way of generating a mutation-like
premalignant lesion in pancreatic cancer, but without the mutation.
So it's panin-like, but without the mutation.
And again,
when you induce those lesions, the ADMs,
the acinar-ductal metaplasia, this is induced genetically by this
transgene from a mouse, they're in between the
acinar and the duct, sort of 50% in between.
They're highly entropic. And then if you look at a single-cell level
at single-cell gene expression, the cells within these lesions
are expressing acinar markers in white, ductal markers in
green. They're expressing the known panin markers from human,
and they're expressing AP1 family members and PI3K family members,
which are canonical measures of stem cell plasticity.
So
it proves that in the earliest stages of pancreatic
cancer, these intermediate lesions on the way to cancer involve
an epigenetic transition zone that's prone to a high degree of
plasticity and that would encourage the tumor to progress further
if it falls into
a state in which it has a growth advantage.
So the other thing that we've been doing, and this is the most recent work, it just
came out like just about a month ago
in
"Molecular Cancer." There was a project that I did with Chris
Iacobuzio, sort of co-led. So Chris
Iacobuzio-Donahue, she's a pathologist.
She ran a program at Hopkins
where she actually had patients as a pathologist.
So she would talk to people who had terminal
cancer and
got them to agree. She's very close to those patients.
It's a very touching personal story of hers that's been written about.
And they would
arrange so that when the patients unfortunately passed away,
she was able to get the tissues from the
primary tumor and from the metastatic lesions at that time, and she
generated xenografts from them. And there were a number of labs that collaborated
with her. It's been an enormous resource.
Bert Vogelstein collaborated with her to try and identify what were
mutations that were present in the primary tumor that gave rise to distant
metastases. So Chris had these lesions.
This is a parental clone of the primary tumor, pancreatic
tumor, and within those
lesionsYou can identify the portions
that go on and form the distant metastasis like in the lung.
You could do it because if you sequence these regions, the passenger
mutations that are present in them define the lineage, and that's how you can get
this sort of clock about how long it takes for those tumors to develop.
So Bert's lab did not find any mutations.
This was work that was done by Alvin Anakosoni working with them.
But we found huge numbers of epigenetic
changes involving a widespread loss of
heterochromatin at H3K9 dimethylation and H3K9
trimethylation regions and increases in
H3K27,
sorry, H3K4 acetylation
as well, H3K9 acetylation as well.
And they were
in the sort of blocks that would be anywhere from a few
kb to hundreds of kb in length. And you can see if you normalize the
ends of these, these are these regions that are present in the region that
gives rise to the metastasis, also in the distant metastasis, and there's
a loss of this heterochromatin by both of
those marks, and there's a loss of DNA methylation within these
domains as well. So it seemed that epigenetic changes in the
primary tumor giving rise to the distant metastasis.
But how could that happen? So,
this just shows that those areas where those
distant metastases are present in the primary tumor, when you make these
xenografts from them, they undergo epithelial-mesenchymal
transition. They become resistant to gemcitabine, all of those things that are
consistent with their becoming metastatic.
So
this project was led by Masama Ada as a postdoc in the lab,
Kenneth Sherman, who's my graduate student, and then Ken Jiao, who's a
collaborating biostatistician at Johns Hopkins.
And they performed a
genome-wide CRISPR screen to identify the genes that are
present in these patient-derived xenografts from the metastasis
that are actually driving their growth.
So are there genes that confer this
increased growth propensity on the metastases, but
not on the xenografts derived from the primary tumors? What are they?
And can we identify the mechanism by which these
presumably epigenetically modified genes are driving distant
metastasis? And the result of that analysis is shown here.
So there's sort of four classes of genes, but the one to focus
on is the group here. These are the genes that, identified by
CRISPR, that promote the growth of the distant metastasis, but not the primary.
So if they promoted the primary, they'd be on this side of the line.
They promote the distant metastasis, they're on this side of the line.
And this is the sort of candidate genes that are
present in that primary tumor that
seem to be, their activation, giving rise to the distant metastasis,
to the growth of those metastases.
And the number one gene on that list was something called KLF5, which is
not KLF4. It's another Kruppel family member.
And it's been known to be involved in cancer.
Expression is high, particularly in colon cancer.
There's a number of papers sort of discuss that, but in terms of it driving
metastasis, that's not known previously.
There are a number of other genes that are in this list, including
splicing factors, ribosomal proteins, things like that.
And if you look at what are the enrichment
leading genes, what are the properties of
the classes the genes fall within, things like chromosome
condensation. This is interesting, the pentose phosphate shunt, because in that
original paper, we found that there was a change in this
OxPPP pathway. So this is consistent.
And then also histone methylation.
So it looks like that could be a good candidate for what's happening.
So KLF5 clearly shows increased expression in the
distant
metastases from these patients and in their xenografts.
In review, the reviewers asked us to go back to human
tumors and see if the human pair tumors of
metastases compared to primary pancreatic tumors show
increased expression, and in the lung metastases, we did this by
collaborating with Anaban Maitra, who had a wonderful single-cell
data set from human tumors that had gotten published in "Nature" two years ago.
If you look at the TCGA data, there is an enormous difference in
terms of patient survival of the relatively small number of people who have
low KLF5 expression. So this seems to be biologically relevant.
And then if you knock down KLF5 expression, it inhibits the
growth of these xenografts markedly,
both in vitro but also
by their migration capacity in Boyden assays.
So they seems to be biologically relevant.
And then here's the
most convincing thing early in this work was that if you do this
knockdown of KLF5, look what happens to the heterochromatin.
It comes back. So that was the defining feature
of what's causing pancreatic cancer metastasis.
This widespread loss of heterochromatin.
It's punctuated in these little block regions throughout the genome.
But when you knock down KLF5, which seems to be driving this based on the
genetic experiments, the heterochromatin comes back.
So maybe it would reverse the thing that gives the tumors the ability
to metastasize in the first place.
And that does not have an effect upon the
primary tumors at all. So
if we did a single-cell RNA
sequencing comparison of paired metastases in primary PDAC
using those same lines,
you can see on thison this plot
that there's a big difference in two clusters of cells, they call them
cluster
five and cluster two,
that show the biggest difference in
their expression between the primary and the distant
metastasis-derived xenografts.
And those are related to stem cell markers, and also
RNA velocity suggests that they could populate the other clusters
if you look at the little arrows there. So EMT, migration, cell death.
So it's all consistent with metastatic capability.
And the KLF5 expression itself, though, is increased in
all of those clusters.
So this might fit this model that
David Tuveson wrote when we first published that "Nature Genetics" paper.
So he wrote a little editorial saying that there's something that's altered the
epigenome that's allowed those cells to invade and get to a distant site,
and we're suggesting that KLF5 or maybe some other genes that are in
that original CRISPR list, but this is the one that we studied,
is something that would endow it with that capacity that would
cause a set of genes to be expressed that would allow them to at least propagate in
distant metastases. So this is how we approach a problem like this, because
there's not a mutation to identify, but we could use methods like this to try and
find what that might be. And if you look at the chromatin itself, remember that
what the main thing that KLF5 is doing is it's increasing the
heterochromatin. So if you do an ATAC single-cell analysis, that's going to
be reduced. And sure enough, you see this big reduction again
in clusters two and five in the euchromatin when you knock down the
KLF5, so it's becoming heterochromatin again, which is consistent
again with these two groups of
genes. The same ones come up when you do it by chromatin
analysis. And then if you look at what are the
transcription factor binding
sites that are in the open chromatin in the metastases.
So that's a way of saying, well, agnostically, if there's a
transcription factor that's driving the metastasis
whose sites are available in the
now euchromatin that's present in what becomes a
distant metastasis, what are they?
And there's a number of things, but these are both major
EMT genes. But look, there's KLF5.
This was an experiment independent of KLF5, but it's identified
from these experiments showing that that's the area that is
different in chromatin between the distant metastases and the
primary. So all of this is consistent with a functional role for
KLF5 in driving this process.
And then the last thing that we did was
ask the question, which genes are regulated by KLF5, which I just
showed you, you know how we identify them, that are also metastasis
drivers. So in other words, they were in that set that
the CRISPR experiments identified,
that also show a change in gene expression when
we knock down the KLF5. And there's five
genes or six genes that fit that criteria.
And of those genes, several of them are epigenetic modifier
genes.
And two we studied in detail. One of them was something called
NCAPD2, which is a condensin gene that's involved in the
complex interactions that define the A and B domains.
So those are the domains that define the boundaries between euchromatin and
heterochromatin cancer, and this is one of the major proteins that establishes
that domain. And the other one is MTHFD1, which is part of
three MTHF genes, not the one that
people study the most, but that's involved in one-carbon metabolism
to generate
methylation in the first place.
And so if you look at what KLF5 does,
if you knock down KLF5, the expression of
NCAPD2 and MTHFD1, they both go down.
So they're epistatic to KLF5. And moreover,
if you knock down NCAPD2, it's also able to restore
heterochromatin to those cells. So this is lying, and so is
the condensin-like gene. So these genes are
lying
in between the chromatin change and the transcription
factor KLF5. So KLF5 is the modulator.
These are epigenetic machinery genes.
And then those genes that are in those clusters that I
told you about, those would be the landscape genes or
the mediators of the metastasis itself.
So all of this fits... This is just the results for the
MTHFD1 showing the same thing. So it fits this
model that I told you about earlier that was in that
review, which sort of anticipated this, where
inside the primary tumor,
there emerges a small group of genes that stochastically
become more expressed. KLF5, by the way, is very sensitive
to stress response. So it's possible that just the
continued inflammation and stress of the primary tumor
leads eventually to it crossing a threshold of expression where it
activates the expression of these modifier genes, which
modify the epigenetic landscape by specifically
affecting particular target genes, which were in those single-cell
clusters that I told you about, including some of these genes here, like
TGFBR, ITGB1, that are EMT
growth and migration genes. And then that would be the cascade, the mechanistic
cascade of how the epigenome is modified in
metastases that leads to
the tumor survival. So as I say, it sort of fits this
model.Pena-Ruiz and Fernandez-Epico wrote an
editorial that came out in the same issue of "Molecular Cancer," suggesting a
domino effect. So KLF5
influences these epigenetic modifiers, which then affect the
target genes, and they are actually flattening the landscape.
But this may really be how metastasis takes place in pancreatic cancer.
Something like this is probably right.
There's going to be a lot more to this story, but this seems to
be a valid explanation for why you get
metastasis when you have pancreatic cancer. So what are we going to do now?
We're going to look for other candidate modulators, look at some of them that were
on that original list. And are there additional mediators?
Is there an epigenetic network? There were six genes that we identified,
so could they interact in some sort of functional way with each other?
This is
a dynamic question that we're asking.
Most epigenetics work in cancer isn't dynamic, including my own.
In other words, we look at the static state, like
in paired samples. But really, the right way to look at this is what's
happening over time and what's the flux, how does this work in a
progressive process? How does it interact with the environment?
I think it's going to take experiments like single cell examination of
tissues, and closer intervals to define that.
I'm also interested in whether or not KLF5 might be an actionable
biomarker. So people will have
mutations in metastasis, but that's after they got
chemotherapy. But before they got chemotherapy, at least as far
as I know, at least in pancreatic cancer, they don't have
additional mutations. Once you start treating them with the gemcitabine, additional
mutations will accumulate. So is there something you can do
that will arrest those metastases while you're giving them these drugs that
you need to give them that are going to increase their survival from two months to
12 months or something like that, but you still don't want the tumor to come back
at 12 months? If you gave an inhibitor of KLF5, there are
some compounds already that have been used in some trials when they were thinking
about colon cancer that could do that conceivably.
So you might be able to stop the tumors from propagating.
They won't develop these additional...
If they can't divide, they're not going to establish any mutation when you treat
them with an anti-cancer drug. So that might be something that
could be used in an adjuvant setting to complement other therapy.
And then, the goal isn't to cure, necessarily, the
person of cancer with an advanced tumors like this.
It's to make it so that if the tumor were to recur,
it would recur much later than other things that are going to
lead to the patient becoming sick from other reasons.
If you could slow it down beyond what their lifespan would've been, obviously, you
don't have to make it all go away.
And so,
the other thing that we're going to do that's more fundamental, is we're
turning back to some of the mouse models, a different one, the
KPC model of David Tuveson. So he had a really interesting cell paper a
few years ago where he showed that in that model, which is a really simple
pancreatic cancer model genetically, it's stochastic.
Well, they always get pancreatic cancer, but it's stochastic whether or not they'll
form metastases. And so I have a student who's working on that
earnestly to find out epigenetically what's different about that, and then relate
that, actually Rong is going to collaborate with us if we get our funding,
and relate that to human tumors and see how that's related to what takes
place when those tumors get established in people.
And I want to just thank our people who contributed in the lab,
and our collaborators.
I mentioned the key ones as I was going along.
And here, if you want more information, here's our lab site.
There's another paper on entropy that just came out recently, and I couldn't put
into this talk. And
please contact me if you're interested in doing something together.
Thanks very much.
Thanks for a great lecture. And we do have time for some questions, if
there are any.
Maybe I'll ask.
UHRF1, I think you mentioned is mutated in
prostate cancer.
When? Is it one of the mutations that
promotes the plasticity that occurs late in
prostate cancer that allows them to become neuroendocrine?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
Great talk. I have a question about the KL5 expression.
You mentioned something about it's sensitive to stress,
the activation of KL5. When you're looking at primary tumor in
human patient samples, do you see
what percentage of tumor cells will
have KL5 expression? And is there any
other features surrounding those cells that are kind of indicating what
might be the stimuli to actually activate those
cells?
It's a great question. I don't know.
One of the reasons I'm interested in collaborating with Rong is he can ask
questions about what's in the local microenvironment.
And the student, Gabe Shatkin, he's already started to do some of this work.
And so we're looking actually at what happens to metastases when they
metastasize.
So we've been working with Peter Friedl in
Holland.
He has this way of looking as the cells immediately get to their
location. Is there something that the tumors are doing?
Is there something that the environment is doing?
These are really great questions, but we haven't gone down that road yet, as I say.
Thank you. Congratulations.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Okay.
Dr. Feinberg, excellent talk. And just a curiosity that
I have is when you have... methylation of
some tumor suppressors and they become the driver genes,
how effective can inhibition of methylation
become in terms of treatment or clinical
significance?
Could you restate the question, please? Sorry.
My question is, when methylation of some
tumor suppressor genes becomes the driver for
metastasis or whatever-
Uh-huh
... then how effective inhibition of
methylation of selective targets can be
used for clinical
application?
Oh, okay. Well, the slide's gone, but
the paper that just came out in
cancer research, the one that I was referring to, by a student of mine who was
looking at AML and identified
two types of mutations in AML that lead to a very
high entropy state. The
genes that are involved in AML directly affect DNA methylation.
So there's a couple of those genes that lead to
a high entropy, high variability state expression.
And we actually used decitabine in those experiments, which
reduced the entropy. So it's conceivable that it might lead to a
modulation of the variability of gene expression.
That's different than the things that we're doing here because this was an example
where the set of steps was you
had a transcription factor, KLF5, that was
affecting the modifiers, but
they weren't
like DNA methyltransferase. Okay?
They were a different way of doing modification of the chromatin, and then they
were having an effect on those genes.
But the one that you're talking about, that's a valid pathway too, and
it may be something related to entropy.
So,
that's a great question. Thank you.
I enjoyed your talk. I was wondering if you could comment on the role of epigenetic
regulation in the metastatic niche or the pre-metastatic niche,
particularly how epigenetics might modify the immune
TMA.
That's a
really good question.
Of course it might, right? So,
tumors generate lots of
things on their cell surface that the
immune cells are going to respond to.
Are you asking about the tumor, or are you asking about the
immune system's epigenome?
The macrophages, the T cells.
Yeah, so their epigenome. I don't think that's studied as much actually.
And it's a fertile area for investigation.
So, in other words, are there epigenetic changes occurring that the
tumor might do that are affecting the immune system, like through an epigenetic
pathway? If that's what you're asking, that's a really neat question.
I don't know a lot about that.
Correlated to that is all these HDAC inhibitors.
Yeah.
Are they working?
Are they working on the immune system?
Yeah, it's a really good question. Yeah.
It's a great question.
Hi. Fabulous talk. Well deserved.
I can't hear you, David.
Fabulous talk.
Thank you.
Very well-deserved award.
Thanks.
So, as you know, right-
Can you get closer to the mic? Sorry.
As you know,
a significant number... Let's say breast cancer.
A significant number of women with breast cancer have circulating tumor cells but
will not develop metastasis.
So my question is,
what is special about those one or two cells
in terms of their epigenetic landscape, and this is a theoretical question, right,
that allows them to go through all the processes to get out of
through the blood vessels and get
into a niche where they can divide and form a metastasis when there's so many,
right?
Is that something that can be looked at?
Can you maybe isolate circulating tumor cells and try
to match the circulating tumor cells with what's in the
metastasis versus what the epigenetic landscape that was in the
original tumor?
I have not worked on that myself, on circulating tumor cells.
There is a
scientist at the Weizmann Institute, and I'm blanking on her name right
now, but she had a paper in "Nature Biotechnology"
last year where she was identifying chromatin changes
in, it wasn't circulating tumor cells, but it was
in these sort of epigenetic particles that you can pick up in
plasma. They're probably circulating nucleosomes.
And they have
this complicated mixture of
euchromatin and heterochromatin features suggesting plasticity
that are on the nucleosomes. One of the things that she mentions in
her work, too,
Efrat Shema. Now I'm getting the name. Okay.
But, is that it's not clear where these cells are coming from.
Where these nucleosomes are coming from.
They
could be coming from inflammatory cells, which is what
the last speaker was asking about.
They could be coming from primary cells, but also they can be coming from
other disease states. And actually, I think that Tommy Cohen at
Hebrew University at Jerusalem, when he was doing his studies of
these
short read, highly methylated signature domains,
and then people have been studying what those are.
And they're not necessarily malignant states, you can pick up some of these.
So there are apparently a number of disease states that can lead
to circulating weird chromatin and
weird DNA methylation. Of course, cancer likely can do that.
And it's a great frontier to study.
I think it's right on the boundary of our ability to perceive
things. The main reason I don't study it is I think to do it, you need
enormous numbers of samples, and I think it's sort of gone kind of
industrial. Like Tommy doesn't study it either.
He did all the work that he did, and then this company,
I forget the name of it, but there's one of these big companies, they've got a
great big bank of things, and they look at them.
So I think that's out there in the private sector where they have the resources to
collect a lot of material, but it's not something I've looked at.
Good question.
Thank you so much for the excellent talk, Professor Feinberg.
I was wondering,
how do you think does the role of ecDNA, extra
chromosomal DNA, fit into the
epigenetics
story that you discussed today with us?
Circular DNA?
Yes.
I do not know. Sorry.
I thought you were going to ask about
something related to the person who won the award,
from who was doing C. elegans work, but I don't know.
There's so much more that I don't know. Here's what I learned.
As I learn more, what I learned is over time, as I learn
more and more, I know a lot already.
The more I learn, the more ignorant I realize that I actually
am.
So my true understanding of what I don't know is definitely
increasing significantly over time. So, sorry, I have no answer to that.
Thank you.
All right. Let's thank Dr. Feinberg again for a great lecture, and
congratulations on this award.
Thanks so much.
I
appreciate it.